deutschland verdaut immer noch die
europawahl und falls sie zu hause gerade
auf jobsuche sein sollten
es sieht so aus als würden demnächst
zwar interessante stellen frei was für
ein schock für union und spd
und schuld am desaster ist nicht der
vollkommen inhaltslose wahlkampf oder
ihre klimapolitik nein schuld ist dieses
verdammte video das noch kurz vor der
wahl aufgetaucht das ne ne nicht das von
ibiza dahin dass andere das von rieso
natürlich in frechen youtube ohne rieso
hätten alle cdu oder spd gewählt und
jetzt müssen die beiden hier plötzlich
um ihren job zittern stelle sich das mal
vor was für ein absturz
kann irgendjemand so einen tiefen fall
nachempfinden
ja klar
wer war der mann
nur 15,8 für die arme spd gerade mal
28,5 für die union vielen dank wie so
vielen dank zu zerstören
ja natürlich hat der hier nicht die wahl
entschieden aber wegen rieso entdecken
die volksparteien plötzlich eine bislang
völlig unbekannte spezies nämlich
sogenannte junge menschen das kommt
davon cdu und spd wenn man jahrelang
hauptsächlich klientel politik macht für
menschen in der sagen wir mal
kompostierung phase was für durch
angesprochen so und ich fürchte die
haben aus dem wahl-debakel wenig gelernt
das merkt man vor allem wenn sie über
sogenannte netz themen reden wir sind
viel an der realen theke unterwegs an
wahlkampfständen die leute sind da ganz
anders unterwegs als an der digitalen
theke
was zum henker ist eine digitale theke
kommt eine frau an die digitale tilg und
sagt guten tag ich hätte gerne iphone
gehackt
du hast für ein quatsch
[Applaus]
das ist ein gigabyte mehr sein so ein
unsinn und statt die schuld für letzten
sonntag bei sich selbst zu suchen längst
ak kaliber ab und zeigt mit ihrem
analogen finger auf youtube und die
frage stellt sich schon mit blick auf
das thema meinungsmache was sind
eigentlich regeln aus dem analogen
bereich und welche regeln gelten
eigentlich für den digitalen bereich ja
oder nein
die frage stellt sich überhaupt nicht es
gelten überall dieselben regeln
beleidigung ist verboten volksverhetzung
auch punkt im internet genauso wie bei
dir zu hause im saarland regeln für das
internet ist jetzt die chefin von der
scharia polizei oder war totales
eigentor und meine ganz andere frage wo
ist eigentlich angela merkel
jetzt mehr ernsthaft die ist doch noch
kanzlerin oder ihr schlimm ist
europawahl ergebnis scheint sie jetzt
nicht so richtig zu schockieren wissen
sie wie die kanzlerin den letzten
sonntag verbracht hat ich sag's ihnen
morgens war sie in ihrem wahllokal in
templin sowie eine ganz normale bürgerin
und hat natürlich wie immer spd gewählt
danach klassische sonntags ritual merkel
guckt zu wie ihr mann den mercedes nash
später hat sich bei lecker bienenstich
noch einmal das sowieso video
reingezogen muss hier über lachen weil
er recht hat zu der zeit hat mehrfach
die panische aka angerufen aber merkel
hat sie eiskalt weggedrückt und nach der
ersten hochrechnung haben sie und jean
claude juncker dann bei einer polo
rotkäppchen sekt darauf angestoßen dass
sie mit der ganzen scheiße bald nichts
mehr zu tun haben
[Applaus]
noch
zu der katastrophe vom letzten sonntag
aber da müssen wir uns mit abfinden mit
so kleinkram wie sterbenden
volksparteien will die merkel gar nicht
mehr belästigt werden die denkt nun auch
international
gestern war sie wissen sie zum beispiel
stargast an der uni harvard in den usa
hier original ami trailer für das event
gestern kein witz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wow
ja
gänsehaut
da fehlte wirklich nur noch in jakes der
best kartoffelsuppe aus der uckermark
wahnsinn oder für ihre harvard rede gab
es gestern standing ovations standing
ovations auch weil frau merkel so
persönlich gesprochen hat zum beispiel
über ihre zeit mit horst seehofer wie
oft habe ich gedacht das halte ich nicht
aus
verständlich dann ging es um ihre zeit
in der ddr ach so egal war eine tolle
rede
eine von denen die sie nur im ausland
hält aber zurück zur tristen deutschen
realität die cdu verliert eine million
wähler an die grünen eine million vor
allem jüngere die sauer sind wegen klima
quiz frage wie kriegt man diese jungen
menschen jetzt zurück hier thomas bacher
ist cdu staatssekretär im
wirtschaftsministerium weiß wie es geht
er twittert diese woche zitat wenn die
erste mal ihr eigenes geld verdienen und
selber spüren wer das alles bezahlen
muss sieht die wahl auch mal wieder
anders aus darauf antworte ich mit
hashtag du hast ja wirklich original gar
nichts geschnallt aber echt schöne haare
immerhin immerhin am mittwoch hat in
berlin endlich wieder unser großartiges
klima kabinett getagt und über konkrete
klimaschutzmaßnahmen jahre recht
diskutiert über förderprogramme für
elektroautos oder steuervorteile für
gebäudesanierung tatsächlich beschlossen
wurde nichts ich bin sehr zufrieden dass
er jetzt in einem arbeitsmodus sind das
ist sehr sehr wichtig toll oder im
arbeitsmodus glückwunsch ich war nie
weise davon ausgegangen dass sie
eigentlich immer im arbeitsmodus zeit
so wie alle anderen die arbeit na ja und
so sind die grünen hat plötzlich
deutschlands neue volkspartei
beziehungsweise volkschor partei
sicherlich auch sicherlich auch weil sie
nicht in der bundesregierung sitzen das
ist immer ideal für die
beliebtheitswerte freuen dürfen sie sich
aber natürlich trotzdem
das war eine wahl zur zukunft europas
lasst uns dieses europa gemeinsam
verenden liebe freundinnen und frauen
tja ja ja da war der teleprompter aus
versehen noch auf bauland eingestellt
das passiert passiert so die grünen sind
die erfolgreichste partei deutschlands
bei den unter 60-jährigen bei den unter
60-jährigen was tun union sebastian
pufpaff bietet jetzt einen youtube
tutorial an dass cdu politikern bei
youtube beibringt wie man mit youtube
umgeht verpufft wie heißt denn ihr kanal
der halle ganz geile idee
ich nenne es cd youtube wenn man nämlich
die worte cdu und youtube ja okay also
bei mir lernen die cdu die basics das
sind ja digitale analphabeten die
chinesische rundfunk und wenn sie mal
die sim karte vom smartphone ändern
müssen guck mir den biber an
jetzt gibt das herkommt die faxen macht
irgendwas so eine steintafel ab gestern
habe ich ihm gesagt sein router sei
kaputt vaart der sich einen termin beim
urologen dem lassen doch die cdu sah
aufwachen youtube ist das neue
politische medium ja also laut einer
aktuellen studie der otto brenner
stiftung ist youtube hauptsächlich
unterhaltung und kommerz auch harry so
redet da ja nicht nur über die cdu dass
sie zu oft ist der hässlichste 20
gesehen habe ja ich habe jetzt zwei
iphone 10
beim eigenen produkte a ha ist nicht
witzig
außerdem also als ob fernsehen jetzt
besser wäre man hat herausgefunden fünf
sekunden rtl töten mehr gehirnzellen als
eine flasche terpentin freuen wir uns
doch dass unsere kids jetzt politisch
sind statt die beleidigte kramp wurst zu
geben werden wir alle zum cdu venture
philipp am tor
und das ist keine ortsangabe regen ok er
ist ja er ist ja der social media gott
einer ganzen generation
am tor der weiß wohl ein hammer hängt
und ja und er stellt sich den kritischen
kommentaren der user felix max neumann
am tor flirtet mit den rentner [ __ ]
henry 29
am tor muss ich mal richtig einkaufen
und eine alte ballack ja da diese nicht
gar nichts
dollar darauf stehen die rentner [ __ ]
brew fleißig den unions zombies hier
immer predige du musst authentisch reden
da machst du noch ein paar sinnlose
blicke in die falsche kamera lässt sie
dabei aber film lagers krisengipfels mit
der hände fuchs ab und so ein bisschen
süß zur seite feierabend ist doch kein
hexenwerk
ja das ist doch jetzt genau wider dieser
herablassende tonfall für den euch die
jungen gerade abstrafen die sind auch
nicht sauer wegen fehlender digital oder
youtube kompetenz sondern wegen ihrer
politik die ja sehr sehr es geht auch um
inhalte
deswegen habe ich ja meinen neffen malte
gebeten mir mal aufzuschreiben was wir
besser machen müssten dann wie du sie
klein scheiße wieder liebhaben walter
groier du kleiner racker also im alter
her dass im ganzen süßer stinken
bisschen aber so ist das in der pubertät
so gehen wir da in sevilla das ist auch
klar weiß er selber also was hat er
aufgeschrieben kohleausstieg deutlich
vor 2038 co2 steuer weniger befristete
jobs für berufseinsteiger mehr geld für
bildung statt für mütter rente und
baukindergeld
ja du meinte dass sie sich erst mal ganz
schön was du hier auch ausgeschrieben
aber interessiert keine sau können wir
aber alles leider auch nicht machen
und das wirst du verstehen wenn du erst
mal dein eigenes geld irgendwann mal
verdienen wird nein nein meinte da doch
lieber ein anderer vorschlag ich setze
mir eine basecap verkehrt herum auf sagt
ganz oft gras oder mega und macht dann
dafür ist das echt mega sebastian wurth
[Applaus]
mut zur kompetenz wahnsinnig wichtig
muss doch alles besser verkaufen sind
die leute super so was gerade in der
berichterstattung vielleicht ein
bisschen kurz kommt nicht nur die union
hat ein sogenanntes kinder problem
sondern auch die sozialdemokratie die
spd holt bei den unter 25 jährigen nur
noch acht prozent
wenn die so weitermachen wird aus der
alten tante spd bald die alte tante spd
ja ja ja die 15,8 prozent bei der
europawahl waren ernsthaft das
schlechteste spd-ergebnis seit 1887 ja
da hat noch kaiser wilhelm regiert und
zwar kann er wieder der erste meine
damen und herren kann man sich nicht
schönreden bitte kann man doch und ich
möchte an dieser stelle sagen dass wir
dort auch viele erfolge erzielt haben
ich nenne beispielsweise cuxhaven
cuxhaven
cuxhaven davon hat august bebel immer
geträumt und andrea nahles muss sich
seit dieser woche tatsächlich ernsthafte
sorgen machen
ja man sägt an ihrem stuhl als
fraktionschefin
das heißt jetzt führen die schon wieder
personaldebatten diese suizide
demokraten
es ist es ist überhaupt nicht mehr
lustig was mit denen passiert
nach dem schlechten abschneiden der spd
bei der europawahl will sich
fraktionschefin alis nun früher einer
neuwahl als bislang geplant
[Applaus]
alte regel wenn sogar die tagesschau
nicht aus lacht dann bist du wirklich
unten angekommen wie geht es weiter mit
der spd ich weiß es nicht aber gernot
hassknecht astrotv mit dem medium gernot
hassknecht so freunde was ist die
zukunft der spd
das versuche ich hier jetzt zu lesen und
zwar aus dem letzten aschenbecher von
helmut schmidt sieht scheiße aus weil
die partei nach dieser historischen
klatsche immer noch nicht kapiert hat
was ihr problem ist deswegen bin ich die
richtige neu anfangen mit altem gesicht
das heißt die altes gesicht
gute frage alle gesichter sind das
geringste problem
das ist auch unfair alle wut nur bei
andrea abzuladen was ist denn mit prinz
valium hier dem scholz spd
finanzminister der persönlich in brüssel
verhindert dass konzerne offenlegen
müssen was sie wo verdienen ein
fantasielose kassenwart der rund um die
uhr nur predigt dass das es darum geht
keine neuen schulden zu machen
eigentlich kommt doch jetzt die probe
aufs exempel nichts mehr das sagen meine
kippen hier eindeutig folgendes wird
passieren die mutlos und sitzenbleiben
natürlich in der coco weil man sich über
details nicht einigen kann wird er so
liga nicht gestrichen und die grundrente
kommt auch nie was wiederum dazu führen
wird dass die wähler im osten der kroko
im herbst an der wahlurne fröhlich zu
rufen
meine vorhersage der absturz geht weiter
und am ende verliert die spd sogar nun
lese ich noch aus den eheringen von gerd
schröder
wann die spd das nächste mal den kanzler
stellt das hier ist eine seriöse sendung
astrotv mit den heute show medien der
umit muss schlecht
du hast recht
ja
traurig was mit der spd passiert
zugelegt haben bei der europawahl die
rechtspopulisten wenn auch nicht so
stark wie erwartet in brüssel bildet
sich gerade eine art ja geisterbahn
fraktionen die versuchen wird die
europäische integration auszubremsen wo
es nur geht mit antworten natürlich auch
unsere afd die elf prozent geholt hat
weniger als bei der letzten
bundestagswahl
woran lag's denn wir mussten auch
einiges erklären
wir mussten erklären warum wir in uns in
ein parlament wählen lassen dass wir
abschaffen wollen ja erklären wir das
doch mal kann man nicht mehr
aber wer weiß vielleicht gibt es in
deutschland auch einfach keinen großen
markt für notorische klimawandel leugner
könnte das sein
sie werden von mir nicht hören es gibt
keinen menschen gemachten klimawandel
sie werden von mir auch nicht hören es
gibt einen menschengemachten klimawandel
ich sage wir haben zweifel dass sie
jetzt schon in der fragestellung drin
haben alleine ist der begriff der
leugnung geht in genau diesen links
ideologischen touch reihen der unser
land krank macht ach so die afg läutet
den menschengemachten klimawandel gar
nicht das wusste ich nicht
glaubst du an den menschengemachten
klimawandel nein hätten wir das auch
geklärt
vielen dank dass der kollege tilo jung
da noch mal nachgefragt hat und weil die
afg in sachsen trotz allem stärkste
partei geworden ist führen wir gerade
zum xten mal eine sehr aufgelegte
sexismus debatte da werden jetzt wieder
zig artikel geschrieben über gebrochene
biographien abgehängte menschen die sich
nicht genug gesehen fühlen alles nicht
falsch aber wahrscheinlich gibt es
inzwischen auch einen harten kern von
wählern die schlicht ein ganz anderes
politisches system wollen der blick auf
die karte zum abschneiden der fdp bei
der europawahl macht jedenfalls wenig
freude
irgendwas an den umrissen erinnert mich
an meine kindheit ich kann man nicht
drauf
was passiert da in den neuen ländern
fragt man sich drei monate vor den
wichtigen landtagswahlen im osten reden
wir drüber mit sämtlichen sachsen die je
für die heute show gearbeitet haben kurz
gesagt mit olaf schubert meine damen und
herren
[Applaus]
oder
sprechen sie es aus
schönreden hilft nicht im osten ist die
afg volkspartei was macht sie da so
stark ich muss jetzt ein bisschen
relativieren also es gibt jetzt in
sachsen schon trotzdem auch noch
aufgeschlossene weltoffene menschen ich
habe mal kein persönlich getroffen aber
die gibt es natürlich kommt der afd
das hohe durchschnittsalter entgegen es
gibt ja in sachsen viele ältere menschen
die das afg programm halt noch original
von früher kennen und und natürlich hat
die ard ein gespür für die ängste der
menschen also ja die eu wird immer
mächtiger und die homo-ehe ist denn da
und das thema migration
das steht ganz oben und das spüre ja
sogar innerhalb meiner eigenen familie
also wenn das thema aufs tableau kommt
meine oma ist also die macht wirklich
voll den fakir also die eine ich habe
zwei also meine oma väterlicherseits und
man dreht und konnten noch wir sind die
in die beiden hottentotten ein
tohuwabohu
wir brauchen ordnung wer den mooren ins
land holt hat für ausreichend sonne zu
sorgen
ja so geht's zur sache und natürlich
dann so diese klischees die ausländer
kommen her nehmen uns unsere
arbeitsplätze weg und das kosi thema
unsere frauen klaus länder kommen jahr
nehmen uns unsere frauen mac dabei hat
natürlich jeder ganz individuelle
erlebnisse als ich für mich muss sagen
ich bin seit über 15 jahren mit meiner
freundin carola liiert ich hatte so
gehofft aber da hat sich noch nichts
beschädigt wo du hingehst geplatzte
träume oder die afd ist jetzt offenbar
die partei für die ost identität ganz
offensichtlich obwohl alle großen stars
hatten aber nachgeguckt wessis sind
bauland morden von storch weide sogar
bernd hocke warum stört dass kein
also immerhin sehen sie aus wie es hieß
also vielleicht meine ich jetzt nicht
abwertend also oder nur ein bisschen
also na ja es geht ja darum also ich
kann für mich sprechen also ich wäre ja
bei den etablierten parteien geblieben
wenn die uns bisschen mehr geboten
hätten aber nur einmal begrüßungsgeld
ist immer so ein bisschen wenig und
dafür hat man ja auch viel genommen so
die diese ganze kollektive identität hat
man uns genommen hat diese gemeinsam das
gefühl früher war so wiesen alle 1
sollst du nur eine frau die bekommen ein
kind ganz normal auf arbeit und dann ist
der brigadier unter die hobelbank
gegangen und entnahm das viertel also
dann dürften dass alle mal anfassen
wurde rumgereicht und nach der armee mit
18 hat man zurückbekommen soll das ist
ja alles alles weg und jetzt geht es
auch noch an die braunkohle
das ist ja der letzte stolz des
ostdeutschen die die braunkohle hat man
ja schon foto denn der extra als
trostpflaster dort hinterlegt jetzt
kommt der kohleausstieg das ist so
genickschlag und deshalb bin ich dagegen
also der ostdeutsche liebt seine kohle
lasst die doch dass sie die dort
ausbuddeln
dann schicken sie drüber und westen und
ihr kratzer heimlich wieder ein wenn
alles gar nicht schlecht jetzt stellen
aber auch fest man muss differenzieren
in den großstädten der neuen länder des
ostens da läuft es nicht so gut für die
afd
es gibt schon ein klares stadt land
gefälle und das primär ist das gefälle
wird immer gefälliger also einerseits
die moderne urbane city dort lebt die
die emanzipierte professorin länder
gerecht lebt sie dort basisdemokratisch
unter ihren artgenossen
und wenn sie das jetzt in so einem
reaktionären bergdorf irgendwo im harz
abgelegen wenn sie das noch anspricht
dann hat sie schon den mühlstein um den
hals also dann
wird sie bei vollmond und wolfsgeheul im
zoom verläuft ganz klar weil
mittlerweile auch die landbevölkerung
weiß hexenverbrennung ist verboten gegen
feinstaub jetzt gibt es ja diese gewagte
theorie
ich bin kein anhänger aber es gibt diese
gewandte theorie die afd müsste mal
irgendwo regieren um sich zu entzaubern
sagt man immer welches bundesland
würdest du dafür opfern
also findet wir werden die
rechtspopulisten regieren finde ich als
versuchsfeld österreich ausreichend ab
doch spitze als würde da jetzt nicht
unsere guten deutschen bundesländer die
sie mit herz gewachsen jedes einzelne
jedes einzelne bundesland hat was also
selbst sachsen anhalt dort gibt tausend
sachen du musst du findest du also jetzt
einfach eins von unseren bundesländern
opfern finde ich nicht okay also so groß
ist deutschland nicht also da
da hätten wir den zweiten weltkrieg
schon gewinnen müssen
guten tag könnte ich sie für ein abo des
heute show you tube kanal als begeistern
schließt gefälligst ein abo ab sofort